benjamin castaldi je sais que je vous ai
fait beaucoup de mal je sais que je vous
ai donné j'ai donné votre numéro de
nombreuses fois ouais mais est ce que
voulait vraiment donner mon numéro soit
ce que vous trouvez que c'est la bonne
solution mais je pense que célestin
numéro que j'ai de queen je vous jure
gelé depuis des années des années sur
bas tout le monde m'appelle que ce jour
numérique que sur ce numéro est alors qu
as tu as dit je vous dire un truc face à
dijon lire un truc ça va être très saint
nom
oui je vous le dis si ultime à dévoiler
mon numéro de téléphone
je ferai un carnage mais rires tu as
quel niveau en lui c'est à dire que je
dévoilerai le numéro de tous les
chroniques si je vous le donnerai les
numéros de tous les chroniqueurs bourde
avec ses cascades inc à votre destin
entre ses mains elle fait pas dans les
stalles du deccan je vous le dis non je
vais vous laisser je vais vous laisser
porter lieu courant de second quart qui
prend 30 secondes pour réfléchir
toujours un moteur bon d'accord on est à
un âge si vous appuyez sur le buzzer ça
veut dire que vous faites partir la pub
et qu'il y aura mon véritable numéro de
téléphone
si benjamin vous avez un petit peu de
pitié compassion mon sens un petit peu
de bon sens vous
vous ne donnez pas mon numéro et tout se
passera bien on passera une très bonne
et les téléspectateurs passeront une
très bonne soirée
voilà les téléspectateurs je vous le dis
mes chéris si vous nous rejoignez 20h49
on est en direct si castaldi donne mon
numéro
je donnerai le numéro de tous est ce que
vous dites ça c'est moi qui dénonce que
possible je veux démarrer par le vôtre
et connaît tous par coeur
on est tous par cas attention castaldi
je veux le silence total vichy et je
veux qu'il prenne sa décision seul face
à lui même avant qu'il ne prenne sa
décision
est-ce que vous avez quelque chose à lui
dire
gyneco ne fait pas ça
j'adore ça mais c'est pas çà et là cani
alors tes couilles benjamin poursuit
ribéry rooney bâle et paris au toit au
s'il vous plaît gilles verdez a bien
changé les missions du bernet castaldi
s'est tu fais ça je te le dis mais avec
une immense amitié je te défonce
ouais octo a su assumer
ludivine c'est un homme sage benjamin
prendra la bonne décision et si tu fais
pas chérie je te jure je te défonce à
jean-michel bon je trouve ce sera un
manque de respect évident pour celui qui
nous nourrit tous les jours
simoneau a nié les 20h50 castaldi
mathieu ce que vous avez quelque chose à
dire major un casting je vois pas du
tout pourquoi nous sommes des dommages
collatéraux eux très bien de votre
agression de castaldi
donc si vous répondez en donnant numéro
de téléphone je donnerai votre adresse
et tu montes sur le ring avec moi louis
monte sur le alors dit matthieu
delormeau
étant donné que je suis votre propre
étage peut donner non seulement votre
adresse mais en plus les clés de chez
vous donne aucun nom n'est pas et en
plus ce n'est pas banal
en plus c'est vrai je n'ai je suis de là
mais à un moment je suis jean michel
maire attention on pourrait passer mais
tout simplement les chéris béchir
castaldi benjamin vous êtes un très
grand animateur
oui j'avais fait des émissions
exceptionnelles les avait une carrière
de fou elle va bien est-ce que ce soir
vous allez tout gâcher pour erin on
prend plaisir solitaire pour un plaisir
solitaire castaldi je sais ça fait des
mois et des mois qu'il envie de se
venger et se venger de son numéro se
venger du chocolat gates se venger de
toutes ces femmes et se venger du
pakistanais
c'est vrai la stalle dit
vous allez avoir 3 2 secondes au prendre
votre décision par seconde
trente secondes c'est à dire c'est un
mélange entre 3,30 et c'est le il n'a
besoin de personne
c'est une des décisions les plus
importantes de sa vie qu'il va prendre
dans un instant castaldi castaldi c'est
à st à elle rit castaldi mon téléphone
est là et j'espère que ce téléphone ne
sonne rappaz castaldi je vais demander à
ce qu'on lance le décompte
est-ce que vous avez quelque chose à
dire avant
quelqu'un ici parce que vous voulez le
sait prendre lui laisser prendre sa
décision seul maxime tu vas te rétracter
immédiatement d'accord thomas daniel ce
que je donnerai le vôtre également
benjamin ta vie va être un enfer si tu
le fais donc réfléchit bien il emmène
moi j'habite post moi je décroche jamais
donc ça me concerne pas beaucoup
lourdeur honnêtement votre discours
était pas parlé non est votre réponse à
la fin lui donner un argument décès de
quatre pires bombe avec l'appui ce n'est
pas vrai j'ai perdu 10 kilos regardez
cette photo francois non non ça va bah
non ça va pas rien mais seulement
bondirait ton père
ouais enfin je me jeu j'ai tout essayé
il ya rien qui marche donc au bout d'un
moment voilà écoute moi bien le régime
comme baba c'est magique la base à des
simples tout cas et makrouds et avec
sympa toi tu iras loin je le sais ça
fait but si vous aussi vous souhaitez
avoir ce corps d'apollon tunis que je
comprends très bien
vous appelez cyril hanouna en personne
voici son numéro de téléphone
[Musique]
j'ai bloqué j'ai mis en mode avion mais
vont regarder c'est un peu tout ça y est
c'est parti c'est parti c'est parti ça y
est c'est parti
alors ils oublient ce numéro ce numéro
je l'avais depuis longtemps je vais
donner le premier numéro les chéris tout
de suite si si si on va donner le numéro
de monde sur l iphone est vachement
[Rires]